it's an amazing success as far as i'm
concerned for somebody your age when you
think about it to have a hit hbo show
for how many years now is
as girls six six i started seven years
ago but now it's been on it
on the air for six seasons so really in
your 20s you had tremendous success
getting this show
yeah and from what i remember is the way
you got into this
is that you made a short film i made a
feature film a feature film for like
fifty thousand dollars yeah
twenty five thousand dollars then i
needed another 25 to i didn't realize
that color correction was a thing so i
raised 25 then i had to raise another 25
to finish
oh my gosh when you say you raised 25
because i want to understand this
the 25 000 is enough to cover all of the
shooting
is that because you shoot it on video i
shot it on video i was it was actually
the first film
to be shot on this canon 5d camera we
were the first feature length to do that
and it was a little tiny camera
that my director photography jody leipz
owned
and we shot the entire movie in my
parents apartment so there was no
location fees
the cast was my mom my sister and my
best friend
jemima who's on girls now right talk
about the time so i this is where i was
leading when you
were first starting out and you were
making student films and all that kind
of thing because everyone says well how
do i make it in show business but your
path was one of a writer
and you made your own films but there
was a point where you got a role
on an hbo series am i correct what was
the name of that series
i believe you're talking about my role
on mildred pierce
that's right mildred pierce you said it
was such a disaster
that that you were on mildred pierce
you're shooting a scene
and while they had you out there to
shoot the scene you heard them
auditioning other people
for your part right they auditioned
extras and i was sent home
you were sent home right i was sent home
and the funny thing is the producer
ended up producing eileen landers ended
up being the executive producer of girls
so the person who was downstairs
auditioning other people for my part
ultimately ended up producing our show
why would you have her
i mean i would think like me i get
completely better
when something like i didn't know i was
a day player i had no idea what
i'd never been on a set besides inside
my own house so i didn't know
anything worked so i showed up that
morning they put me in hair and makeup
as a nurse from the 1940s 1930s
and the big problem was that todd haynes
one of my favorite filmmakers
had only seen me audition for a
different role
and he'd also cast me sort of based on i
remember what it was which is he wanted
my friend merritt weaver and she was
unavailable and someone went how about
this girl and he was like okay that's a
different chubby girl that seems fine
i showed up i had no idea i asked my mom
for advice
which was the worst idea and i said look
at these lines with me and she said
they're hiring you to be yourself just
go there and be yourself
no they want you to be someone else
they're hiring you to be a nurse
from the 1940s yeah so like the lines
were like
i remember the line was like her fever's
looking ma'am her fever's breaking
she should be fine by morning time or
whatever and i didn't know how to say it
in the 19th so i was like
so like her fever's breaking she should
be fine by the morning but like
let's check in and then this dialect
coach like swooped in
and was like actually you need to do it
like roll your
r's it's a whole 40s thing and i just
i mean i had true dissociative anxiety i
remember thinking
if i collapse right here they'll have to
take me home in an ambulance and that
will be better for everyone involved
you've said you don't like being an
actress right you you you'd rather just
be behind the scenes being a director
and writer and
maybe after girls is over that's all
you're going to do right you're not
going
to want to be in front of the camera
well i like if i have a friend who has a
project and i feel like we understand
each other
i can appreciate that or if there's some
an opportunity for me to
if i think i have something to bring to
it and i have a conversation with the
director and we think that we can do
something cool i'm excited to try it but
like i have no interest in like i would
never like go out looking for a part in
a movie
is it a rush for you to think about that
you took all these people like allison
williams and this one that one
you cast them in a show and now they all
have careers is that some sort of
satisfaction on your part
it's not like a creepy god-like thing
where i'm like i did it all but i do
love seeing
people i love who are talented and i
mean there's not one member of our cast
who i can't get behind
talent wise personality wise i think
they're all
have their hearts in the right place and
their souls on the right side of history
so it's like i feel good about having
only that jenny and i have only sent
people into the world who
are making it a better place did those
people have to audition for you did all
of them have to
your myma did not jeremiah had to like
beg to be on the show
she'd been in my movie right she was
great in my movie and then i'd written
this part for her and we auditioned like
300 girls 300 great smart professional
girls but none of them had
the quality and also jemima and i had a
chemistry that came from you know
at that point 15 years of friendship
that just wasn't
i couldn't replicate with someone who i
was meeting in an audition did hbo ever
say to you why don't you get somebody
who's got a name
because you weren't a name at that point
there wasn't anyone
hbo has been so supportive they have
truly only ever given us like
smart emotional notes like we haven't
had the typical tv experience of like
being i mean the people who've worked
with us have gotten us to such an
extreme degree
right so there's no if anything they say
like push it further
do what you need to do i feel extremely
let's just say there's nothing i felt
like i wasn't allowed to explore